the battle for Bradford West firebrand
political veteran George Galloway of the
respect party versus labor newcomer
nurse shark
an election novice with incredible
personal story public grounds personal
attacks online trolling and accusations
of smearing all part of a contest being
investigated by police this is how the
election was won and lost in the wildest
contests
the general election in Bradford West
should have been straightforward just
three years ago George Galloway won a
healthy 10,000 vote majority here in a
by-election that shocked many no more so
than the Labour Party who'd held the
seat for more than 30 years this is
George Galloway asking for your support
on the 7th of May election day in
Bradford and in Britain do anything I do
I'm one of the few politicians thank you
thank you very much thank you I'm one of
the few thank you thank you I'm one of
the few politicians who actually does
enjoy elections straightforward straight
talking straight to victory with your
support across the city the Labour Party
campaign style is very different
Kath peel it's the laser machine in full
flow isn't it it is indeed yes and
although this looks like a standard
Labour Party operation challenge and as
Shar is far from a standard Labour
candidate we need to get two guys out
once Cameron ones Cole Galloway anyway
the local community activist was
selected late after the party's first
choice dropped out but she soon made
headlines with her personal story
according to his char she grew up in
poverty and was forced into an arranged
marriage in Pakistan and the age of 15
she was also left to bring up her
sisters after her mother was jailed for
murdering her abusive partner describing
herself as a survivor she's determined
to win the election despite Labour's big
loss in 2012 let's be really clear about
it as one of a constituent said it was a
circus when a circus comes into town it
makes a lot of noise and it gets
everybody's attention he's doing that
now there isn't it well no because if
you see the respect to us now it goes
round yesterday it went past my office
with two people on board but I saw
you're learning the Quran it's not clear
how things got so personal between their
char and George Galloway but it first
came to a head this hustings TMP and for
me the both of us being back the
question about the now boys in
Parliament but he's never there but he's
too busy earning Lords elsewhere you
claimed and gullible journalists
believed you that you are subject to a
forced marriage at the age of 15 but you
are not 15 you are 60
it didn't take long for the marriage
certificate incident to spread on the
internet both sides accusing each other
of lying police have confirmed they're
investigating alleged smears on and
offline the animosity spilled out onto
the streets do you think that the the
campaign between George and his labor
rival has been quite fierce Phil I've
seen their distasteful a lot of dirty
linen has been aired which did it need
to be but it would appear that some
would think that that's that's going to
get them their votes what do you think
Romney is distasteful I think a lot of
it silly you know the go beyond politics
Judy it's quite bitter yeah yeah very
much so
tell your mum and dad you've met me huh
just spoken to a man in the street in
the last school we're at who said that
it's it's out of order that the tactics
that perhaps you respect to using and
labouring using well of course I don't
know what tactics he's referring to but
the
reality is if you make your life story
the central part of your election
campaign you're responsible for what
happens next
I've been speaking to people on the
doorstep they're sort of put off a
little bit by all this do you know what
people people rightfully saw rightfully
saw because at the end of the day the
policies what you've got to do is look
at the policies let's bring it back to
policy let's look at what would you say
that but actually I've been with you all
morning and you always talk about George
before you talk about policies well no
because people need to know we've got
somebody who doesn't vote on Parliament
doesn't vote on our issues now that is
policy if you've got an MP what is a
drawl of an MP let's be really clear
it's about voting for you it's about
being there it's about representing your
voice in Parliament if you're not there
no policy is going to be there is it
Bradford West was already a complicated
constituency home to a large Pakistani
population of around 43% politics has
historically been dominated by the
battery system where old clan has voting
blocs
mr. Galloway navigated this system to
great effect in 2012 but he also gained
passionate support from young people
George Galloway has been a huge
inspiration for me as an artist it's
been a pleasure painting he's you know
doing his paintings facing me and I just
admire you know what he stands for I
admire
he's honesty of his fearlessness and I
think the the saying gorgeous George
you know fits in very well as well but
in some parts of this seat Galloway
didn't seem to have as much support with
it well don't you agree with something
about just God
on every level yeah most level just yeah
it showed himself up on Big Brother
you're right Ferb
the Fido Bradford West election debate
was a live TV show on Islamic channel
umar TV hopefully we're going to try to
structure in a way that that keeps away
from the personal vicious stuff that
we've seen already in Bradford West it's
seven o'clock live from the studios over
my channel i'm mohammed rafi despite the
hosts best intentions it went to similar
way to other meetings once again the
other candidates were almost sidelined
common thing then from these what's the
campaign in general been like for you as
you know because this is a very well
watched campaign isn't it probably not
not the nicest reasons we knew that I
hoped I would be able to cope and get
the message across but going to that
first hush things and sitting there and
having the controversy continued into
the final few days a Jewish journalist
claimed he was physically assaulted by
respect party supporters an allegation
hotly disputed by George Galloway
and then on polling night mr. Galloway
was reported to police for allegedly
breaking election law with the tweet
about polling in the end wasn't even
close - are winning are well over 11,000
votes how did you do it there was a
couple of strategies I used one was
about knocking on doors and one of the
things that I did with women was I asked
every woman to give me her word that she
would talk to another two women and
winner of the two women and I got that
and in your victory speech you said that
that George Galloway had demeaned
democracy but you gave almost your fair
share
do you regret any of the way that you
and I think I think that's a
misconception I really really would like
to clarify that at no point bother
comment about the marriages did I ever
attack George Galloway personally I gave
equally I gave a good fight of course I
did I absolutely did that was why
wouldn't I because that is what
democracy is and that's what election
fighting election is but if anybody was
to say I gave him I did it on his terms
and that's absolutely fun I think could
be traveled it was travesty and just
justice if somebody ever said put me in
that same box so you didn't fight fire
with fire
no I thought I thought I thought that
fire with water and the fire there was
doubt so there you go that shahe started
another chapter in her story that had so
many captivated
as for mr. Galloway and the respect
party they say they've done nothing
wrong in this election and are taking
legal action against Labour's campaign
in the hope to have the result
overturned Joe tiny Sky News in Bradford
West